The Tower of Babel,
the story of how one original language shattered into many was one of humanity's
early attempts to explain languages.
Thousands of years later,
linguists investigated exactly how language has evolved when they put the pieces
together though.
Did it look anything like the Babel story or was this just a tall tale?
So the story goes,
the whole Earth once spoke the same language via he wholehearted stuff.
I have one day they traveled to the land of Sheen odd where they work together
to build a city with a Mcdonald's,
a tower to reach to the skies there.
Supreme Deity wasn't having it though and scrabbled their language so they could
no longer understand each other.
This story's stuck.
Jewish writers speculated what the original adamic language was and how many
tongues it's split into.
Was it 70 or 72 a Persian contended a demic might be Syriac.
Well,
this Syrian went with Hebrew.
Europeans claimed everything from Swedish to Irish,
which apparently just picked out the best bits of those 72 original flavors.
Still Hebrew remained the prime candidate after all.
It's the language of this story,
right?
Detail's changed,
but the interpretation held one original tongue at a single place in time broke
into a bunch of distinct languages in order to keep people from coordinating and
understanding each other.
Then came the 17 and 18 hundreds.
Explorers and trade routes strength the world distant people discovered each
other's languages for the first time.
Intrigued scholars found common patterns that shifted our view of the world's
languages.
Some languages consistently look to tweak away from each other.
Take Arabic and Hebrew,
the the IV Waconda and Zaha behind these words.
There's a regular sound correspondence where Arabic has the Hebrew has zine.
These were cognates,
the same word,
evolving differently in different languages.
Comparing cognates,
a picture emerged of a family tree walking back up the branches of the tree.
You could reconstruct the common ancestor,
but testing this method in the wild world.
The trails of cognates didn't lead back to a single protal language.
No,
there were clusters of closely and distantly related languages belonging to
separate families.
English,
Irish,
Greek,
and even Sanskrit were clearly part of an Indo European language family from the
South China Sea to the eastern Pacific.
The languages of Austrian.
Nisha all share their own common ancestor and Hebrew.
Once dubbed,
the original language fits snuggly among its kin.
One twig of an Aphrodisiac family.
It wasn't even the purest or best preserved twig.
For example.
It wore away consonant distinctions that its relatives,
Aramaic,
and Arabic kept also change,
turned out to be something languages were doing naturally all of the time.
Babel still held one intriguing idea over us though that original language.
See reconstructions dead ended several thousand years back.
Beyond that,
historical linguists started to feel like they simply had nothing to say.
Nothing to say,
ah,
well tie your own hands,
but you can't hold back a maverick.
So you established families and reconstructed parent languages.
Well,
why not do the same thing again?
Compare Prodo languages for cognates and build families on top of families.
Families are coming together.
It's a super family entered the late Joseph Greenberg classify languages first.
He said,
then compare and reconstruct.
Classify first.
Yes,
it's called mass comparison.
Take a huge number of languages and look for patterns in them,
patterns and vocabulary,
but also in their topology,
the comparative structure of the world's languages.
You know,
stuff like how many vowels does it have?
What's its basic word?
Order?
He cast his net wide and cut some huge and controversial super families into
European Turkic Mongolian Japanese and more belonged to your Asiatic and this
one drew tons of flack,
but the complicated languages of the Americas are one happy Amarin to family.
Then in the nineties merit Ruhlin ran all the way he compared vocabulary from
across the globe and reconstructed 27 Prodo words.
Here it was our first look at the parent of all living tongues,
prodo world or pro human and produce sapiens if that's your style.
Prodo world had words like thick,
cool Ma Aqua [inaudible].
A decade later,
he went after the type pathology of Proto world.
Apparently our ancestors spoke their sentences with a subject than an object
than a verb.
They put adjectives before nouns,
and instead of prepositions,
they used post positions where we finally staring into the face or the tongue of
that long lost the original language.
Historical linguists said,
Nah,
and they tore into these results.
These short words could easily be chance look alikes.
You can't account for borrowings.
The meanings of your cognates are all over the place were flimsy method.
Let's you base reconstructions on irrelevant evidence.
Thus,
they confidently tossed mass comparison into the bins of fringe linguistics,
pseudoscience.
And yet babbles first and biggest claim lingers.
The mavericks still swear we're onto something.
Are we or are they telling yet another tall tale?
Stick around and subscribe for language.